El 3 de noviembre de este año, Imran Khan,
el exprimer ministro de Pakistán sufrió
un intento de asesinato. Meses antes, en abril
de este mismo año, este hombre había dimitido
tras una moción de confianza en el parlamento.
Si habláramos de otro país, diríamos que
Pakistán está en una crisis política realmente
preocupante. Sin embargo, este tipo de noticias
son casi la norma en este país. Pakistán
lleva sumido en el caos político y económico
desde su independencia.
Pero, os estaréis preguntando, ¿qué me
importa a mi Pakistán? Pues, queridos amigos,
Pakistán os debería importar, y mucho, por
tres simples razones: la primera es que es
el 5º país con más población del mundo,
¡más de 220 millones! Además, es de los
pocos países del mundo con armas nucleares,
y su doctrina nuclear es de “gatillo fácil”.
En teoría, basta con que alguien invada su
territorio para que puedan lanzar una bomba
nuclear ¡Pero esperad porque todavía hay
una tercera razón! Terrorismo. Pakistán
tiene toda clase de grupos terroristas...
en muchos casos apoyados por el propio estado.
De hecho, ¿sabéis dónde mataron a Osama
Bin Laden? Efectivamente, en Pakistán. Y
no en un zulo cualquiera, sino en la ciudad
de Abbottabad, que para que os hagáis una
idea, es el Beverly Hills pakistaní.
¿Cómo podría alguien ignorar a un país
como Pakistán que parece que a la mínima
va a estallar? La verdad que entran escalofríos
solo de pensar en que el quinto país más
poblado del mundo, que además tiene armas
nucleares y que está plagado de terrorismo,
acabe cayéndose en pedazos. Y es que la situación
en Pakistán es crítica: tras décadas de
inestabilidad, ahora mismo están al borde
del colapso. Pero, ¿cómo ha llegado hasta
este punto Pakistán? ¿Por qué está tan
sumamente mal? ¿Qué es lo que le está lastrando
tanto? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero
antes vamos a
ver un poco de historia.
T1 (LA CAJA DE PANDORA PAKISTANÍ)
¿Sabías que en Pakistán nunca, ningún
primer ministro que haya ganado unas elecciones
ha acabado su mandato? Pakistán lleva sumido
en las tinieblas de la inestabilidad política
desde su creación. De hecho, el intento de
asesinato a Imran Khan no es más que otro
de una larga lista en la caótica historia
de Pakistán. Y, la verdad, viendo cómo han
acabado otros en su mismo cargo, ha tenido
bastante suerte.
Porque, ¿sabéis cómo acabaron el resto?
Pues O acusados de corrupción y en la cárcel,
O exiliados o incluso asesinados, como la
única Primera Ministra mujer que ha tenido
el país, Benazir Bhutto. A la que asesinaron
cuando estaba presentándose para un tercer
mandato. Así que, bueno, creo que, cogéis
la idea.
Pero frenemos un poco para entender por qué
Pakistán está como está. Veréis, Pakistán
se independizó en 1947 del Imperio Británico,
como la India. Pero la Pakistán que conocéis
no es la que se independizó.
(Cuando PWakistán se liberó de las cadenas
británicas, estaba dividido en dos territorios:
el Pakistán del este y el del oeste.
Es decir, lo que ahora es el Pakistán que
conocemos y Bangladesh. Pronto surgieron tensiones
étnicas que llevaron a una guerra civil que
terminó por separar ambos territorios. Y
en 1973, casi dos años después del fin de
la guerra, Pakistán aprobó una nueva Constitución.
Esta Constitución reconoce el Islam como
religión oficial aunque también acepta algunos
elementos de secularismo.)
Por supuesto, Pakistán no es ni mucho menos
una democracia perfecta. Y de hecho, queridos
amigos, tiene dos grandes problemas: su seguridad
y sus instituciones políticas.
Veréis, el ejército domina todo el funcionamiento
de la sociedad y no se le escapa una.
Lógicamente, entre sus cometidos está la
seguridad del país. Pero su estrategia contra
la eterna enemiga India es bastante drástica.
De hecho, el propio ejército la bautizó
con el nombre de “desangrar a la India con
mil cortes”. Y, ¿en qué consiste? Muy
simple: entrenar a insurgentes y desestabilizar
a la India. Por eso, no extraña que nos encontremos
con noticias como esta:
C1(Pakistán entrenó a grupos clandestinos
de militantes para luchar contra India en
Cachemira, admitió el ex presidente paquistaní
Pervez Musharraf en una entrevista con SPIEGEL.)
Pero no creáis que solo ha financiado a estos
grupos para desestabilizar a la India. Fijaos
en lo que dijo el propio exPrimer Ministro,
Imran Khan:
(“El ejército pakistaní (...) entrenó
a Al Qaeda y a todos estos grupos para luchar
en Afganistán” – Imran Khan)
Vamos, que ni los propios dirigentes pakistaníes
niegan que hayan financiado a grupos terroristas.
Y, ¿a quién creéis que le está afectando
ahora? Efectivamente, a Pakistán.
Como podéis ver, Pakistán está repleto
de grupos terroristas activos, que atacan
continuamente ciudades y pueblos del país.
No se salva ni la propia capital, Islamabad.
Y, por si esto fuera poco, los pobres ciudadanos
del país han tenido que tragar con gobiernos
tremendamente inestables hasta el día de
hoy. Golpes de estado como el de 1977 o el
de 1999, corrupción sin freno, asesinatos
de políticos… Vamos, una odisea. Y, ¿adivináis
por cortesía de quién? ¡Exacto! Lo habéis
adivinado: el ejército otra vez. El ejército
se ha dedicado a quitar y poner a primeros
ministros a diestro y siniestro, y muchas
veces con la ayuda de los jueces. Y os preguntaréis,
¿por qué está el ejército tan interesado
en manejar la política? Por una sencilla
razón: para proteger sus intereses económicos.
Veréis, el ejército es dueño directo de
más de 50 empresas y se cree que a través
de fundaciones tiene miles de empresas más
bajo su control.
En total el ejército pakistaní estaría
involucrado en negocios valorados en más
de 20.000 millones de dólares.
Y no son empresas cualquiera, sino empresas
que copan casi todos los mercados nacionales
en los que están, como el del cereal, el
de los fertilizantes o el de la distribución
de gas.
Claro, como os podéis imaginar, en cuanto
ven sus intereses en peligro no dudan en acusar
al primer ministro de turno de corrupción.
Como comprenderéis, en un país con tanta
inestabilidad política, un ejército con
empresas clave en el país que actúa solo
para ganar dinero, e inseguridad, la decadencia
económica está asegurada.
Y claro, si a esto le unimos que Pakistán
apenas produce gran cosa, a excepción de
unos cuantos mangos, aceites vegetales y camiones,
pues ya tenemos el póker de ases. De hecho,
la balanza comercial es realmente pésima.
Fijáos:
De entre los tres grandes países del subcontinente
indio, Pakistán es el que peores datos tiene
en cuanto a lo que suponen las exportaciones
en el PIB. Es un indicador de su pobre apertura
al exterior y la pobre competitividad de sus
empresas.
Pero, claro, si todos los problemas de Pakistán
fueran estos, pues tampoco estaríamos haciendo
este vídeo. Atentos, porque esto solo acaba
de empezar.
T2 (EL MEJOR AMIGO DE PAKISTÁN)
Si quisierais poner unos paneles solares en
vuestra casa y no tuvierais dinero, ¿qué
haríais? Pedís un préstamo, ¿no?
Pues en cierta forma Pakistán ha hecho lo
mismo - aunque cambiando inversión por gasto
corriente. Como ha querido ofrecer servicios
públicos pero no tenía dinero porque su
economía no da para más, se ha endeudado.
El país tiene una deuda tan grande como el
70% de su PIB. Y ya se lo que me vais a decir:
A ver, un 70% no parece tan alto si lo comparamos
con otros países como España, por ejemplo,
que está en el 120%.
Es verdad, pero la diferencia es que Pakistán
no tiene una economía tan desarrollada como
para soportar semejante nivel de endeudamiento.
El riesgo político, la falta de ingresos
públicos, y todos los problemas que os hemos
descrito hacen que 1) la demanda por deuda
pakistaní sea muy baja y 2) Que los tipos
a los que se financian sean mucho más altos.
Y si tenemos en cuenta estos factores: menos
dinero disponible e intereses más altos,
entonces el 70% sí que se convierte en un
problema.
De hecho, sus bonos están calificados como
bonos basura. Porque, claro, la pregunta es:
¿Quién en su sano juicio les prestaría
dinero? Pues a parte del FMI o el Banco Mundial,
su mejor amigo: China. Exacto, el gigante
asiático es el principal acreedor de Pakistán.
(Pakistán fue uno de los primeros países
en reconocer a China en 1951. Ambos tenían
un adversario común: la India. De hecho,
con el estallido de la guerra entre la India
y China en 1962, ambos países empezaron a
cooperar militarmente. En los últimos años,
casi un 40% de las exportaciones de armas
de China van a Pakistán. En los años 90,
esta cooperación se extendió al terreno
económico y, desde 2015, acordaron crear
un corredor económico.)
Y ya se lo que me vais a preguntar, ¿de verdad
le interesa tanto a China comerciar con un
país que apenas se sostiene? Pues lo cierto
es que sí. Atentos a este mapa.
Lo que veis aquí es el Puerto de Gwadar,
construido por China. Este puerto podría
llegado el caso ser el salvavidas de China
¿Por qué? Pues seguid mirando el mapa.
China compra petróleo a los países árabes.
Ese petróleo viaja por barco y pasa por las
costas de la India. En cualquier momento,
la India, Estados Unidos o alguno de sus aliados
podría cortar el tránsito. Bastaría con
cerrar estos tres estrechos que veis en pantalla
para bloquear todo el tránsito de petróleo
hacia china.
Sin embargo, si estos barcos atracan en Pakistán,
podrían enviar el petróleo por tierra. Es
decir, que la India o Estados Unidos no tendrían
tan sencillo cortar el tránsito.
Y a ver, esto le va a venir muy bien a China,
pero…¿qué saca de esto Pakistán? Pues
unos 62.000 millones de dólares en proyectos
de construcción de infraestructuras. Si Pakistán
quiere tener una economía productiva, necesita
puertos, ferrocarriles y carreteras. Y muy
pocos se atreverían a poner el dinero en
la mesa para construirlos ¿Por qué? La respuesta
está en una palabra: terrorismo.
Pakistán está plagado de grupos terroristas:
Al Qaeda, Talibanes, grupos independentistas...
¡La lista es interminable! Y todo esto hace
que incluso China tenga problemas cuando quiere
construir un puerto. Atentos.
N1 (26 de abril de 2022, Pakistán: Ciudadanos
chinos asesinados en un atentado en Karachi.
Aljazeera)
Para que os hagáis una idea, China ha llegado
a proponer que amurallen todo el puerto de
Gwadar para protegerlo de grupos terroristas.
Y todo esto explica que esos préstamos de
China vengan con unos intereses más altos
que los del FMI. Donde el FMI cobra un interés
del 3%, China sobre un 6,5%.
En otras palabras: Pakistán es muy poco productivo,
tiene mucho riesgo y, a la vez, mantiene una
deuda salvaje con el FMI y con China.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué tal se llevan con
Estados Unidos? Pues, como os podéis imaginar,
las relaciones están en “Es complicado”.
Por un lado, Estados Unidos es el principal
mercado de productos pakistaníes. De lo poco
que exporta Pakistán va, el tío Sam es el
comprador más importante. Ahora bien, en
el terreno político, las relaciones no son
buenas.
Durante la guerra fría, Pakistán fue un
aliado contra la Unión Soviética.En aquellos
años, Washington entrenó a grupos insurgentes
para que lucharan contra los soviéticos.
Sin embargo, todo cambió cuando Pakistán
inició su programa nuclear. De un día para
otro, la Casa Blanca cortó todo el suministro
de armas hacia este país. Pero, sin duda
alguna, la manzana de la discordia es el terrorismo.
Pakistán es un lugar refugio para un montón
de grupos terroristas.
Pensadlo bien: Osaba Bin Laden estaba “escondido”
(((HACER GESTO DE COMILLAS CON LAS MANOS)))
en un buen barrio de las afueras de Abbottabad.
Su casa estaba a poco más de un kilómetro
de la Academia Militar de Pakistán. Así
que prácticamente eran vecinos… Pero por
supuesto nadie sabía nada.
Es más, cuando los Navy SEALS entraron en
la casa donde estaba Bin Laden, tuvieron que
invadir el espacio aéreo de Pakistán. Esto
no le hizo la más mínima gracia al Gobierno
pakistaní. Pero todo esto es tema para otro
vídeo.
Hoy nos vamos a centrar en la crisis de este
país. Como decíamos, Pakistán está endeudado
hasta las cejas. Es más, quieren pagar la
deuda que ya tienen... ¡Con más deuda!
Como os podéis imaginar, esta es la receta
perfecta para terminar en un colapso de proporciones
nachovidalianas. Sólo hacía falta un evento
sorpresa para terminar dando al traste con
todo el país. Y los últimos años han estado
llenos de eventos sorpresa. Ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver.
T3 (KHAN, ¿LA GRAN DECEPCIÓN?)
¿Habéis visto los vídeos que hemos dedicado
a la crisis energética en Europa? Si recordáis,
en estos últimos meses, la consigna en Europa
ha sido “pagaremos lo que haga falta con
tal de llenar nuestros depósitos de gas”.
Eso implica que muchos barcos de Gas Natural
Licuado que iban con destino a Asia dieran
la media vuelta y se fueran a Europa, donde
pagaban mucho más.
Todo esto son, relativamente, buenas noticias
para Europa. Pero hay un claro perdedor: los
países asiáticos que se quedan sin gas.
¿Y quién ha sido uno de los grandes afectados
por esta crisis? ¡Exacto! Pakistán.
Veréis, en estos últimos cuatro años, Pakistán
ha sufrido varios cambios políticos y económicos.
Los grandes partidos políticos, el Partido
del Pueblo y la Liga Musulmana de Pakistán
de Nawaz han visto su dominio en peligro.
(Para que os hagáis una idea, el Partido
del Pueblo es el partido que más veces ha
gobernado en Pakistán. Por hacer un resumen
rápido, podríamos decir que son lo más
parecido a un partido socialdemócrata occidental.
La Liga Musulmana, sin embargo, sería el
equivalente a un partido conservador)
Sin embargo, en el año 2018, apareció el
clásico outsider de la política llamado
a romper con el bipartidismo. El típico líder
carismático que promete maravillas en campaña
electoral. En este caso, se trataba de toda
una estrella del cricket, que es el deporte
nacional en Pakistán ¡Exacto! Estamos hablando
de IMRAN KHAN.
El partido de Imran Khan se presentó a las
elecciones de 2018 prometiendo mejorar la
economía y construir un estado de bienestar
bajo un socialismo islámico. Además, como
los dos grandes partidos del país estaban
podridos de corrupción, aprovechó para presentarse
también con un mensaje anti-corrupción.
¡Y acabó ganando! Por desgracia, la suerte
no le acompañó en su presidencia. Poco después
de ganar, tuvo que enfrentarse a su primera
crisis: la crisis del Covid.
Ya sabéis que la crisis del Covid frenó
toda la economía mundial en seco, y Pakistán
no iba a ser una excepción. Y si su economía
ya estaba estancada de por sí, la crisis
del Covid no le pondría fácil mejorar ¡Pero
esperad un momento porque esto es sólo el
principio!
¿Cuál es la principal fuente de energía
en el mix de Pakistán? ¡Exacto! El gas natural.
Sin embargo, este país no tiene ninguna conexión
internacional a través de gasoductos. Han
intentado construir uno con Rusia y otro con
Irán. Pero, por el momento, ninguno de estos
proyectos se ha materializado.
Pues bien, Pakistán produce algo más de
la mitad del gas que consume, pero el resto
lo tiene que importar. Y ¿Cómo llega el
gas a Pakistán? ¡Exacto! Por barcos de gas
natural licuado. Como sabéis, el gas natural
licuado es mucho más caro que el gas que
llega por gasoducto. Y en Pakistán, el dinero
no sobra, precisamente ¿Conclusión?
(Un apagón eléctrico en todo el país pone
a Pakistán en la oscuridad)
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esta noticia
es de ANTES de la Guerra de Ucrania! Es decir,
antes de que esos barcos metaneros dieran
la vuelta antes de llegar a los puertos de
Pakistán y se marcharan a Europa. Así que
ya os podéis imaginar lo que está ocurriendo
ahora, en pleno 2022. Apagones masivos, precios
altísimos por la energía y fábricas paradas.
¿Conclusión? Todo ese estado del bienestar
y esa economía próspera que prometió Imran
Khan en campaña electoral parece una broma
de mal gusto en este momento. Mientras tanto,
los acreedores quieren recuperar sus deudas.
Y Pakistán ha terminado devaluando su propia
divisa.
Como podéis ver, 1 dólar estadounidense
ha pasado de costar 100 rupias en 2017 a costar
más del doble en 2022 ¿El resultado? Aún
más inflación para los ya sufridos ciudadanos
pakistaníes.
Si os fijáis bien, a Khan se le estaban acumulando
los mismos síntomas que presentaba Sri Lanka
antes de colapsar y de lo que ya hemos hablado
en este canal: deuda elevada, inflación NACHOVIDALIANA,
moneda devaluada y escasez.
Por eso, como parecía que Khan era incapaz
de solucionar todos los problemas que se estaban
acumulando, el 10 de abril de 2022 le echaron.
Y la diferencia con el resto de primeros ministros
de antes que él es que al menos no le acusaron
de corrupción, sino que fue el propio Parlamento
el que le echó a través de una moción de
censura. Es la primera vez que en Pakistán
echan de esta manera a un Primer Ministro.
Desde entonces, Pakistán tiene un gobierno
provisional. En este caso, la Liga Musulmana,
de centro derecha, ha vuelto al poder. Ya
han dicho que no convocarán nuevas elecciones
hasta haber hecho algunas reformas para estabilizar
el país. El nuevo presidente, SHAHBAZ SHARIF,
tiene una tarea colosal por delante.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿Cómo
creéis que el nuevo gobierno solucionará
todos estos problemas? ¿Qué creéis que
debe ser su prioridad? ¿Acabará Pakistán
como Sri Lanka? Y, si fuera así, ¿qué implicaciones
creéis que tendría para la seguridad internacional?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribiros a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
saludo y hasta pronto.